Telepathic dogs, eerily topical pandemics,
mass infertility.
When it comes to zombies, disease, or mass
extinction, these films are the cream of the crop.
Apocalyptic films are teeming with the walking
dead, nuclear threats, and catastrophic plagues.
But only one film on this list sees the world
sizzle to a crisp thanks to dragons.
Set in the totally-not-apocalyptic year of
2020, where dragons have replaced mankind
as the dominant species, the paltry remnants
of the human race must work together to ensure
their survival.
Maligned upon its release and criminally under-seen,
Reign of Fire is much more interesting, visually
stunning, and sophisticated than its goofy
premise suggests.
With an all-star cast and some genuinely jaw-dropping
creature effects, it's a must-watch for anyone
who wants to see the world burn.
This loose adaptation of Richard Matheson's
classic novel follows scientist Robert Neville
who is, as far as he can tell, one of the
last human beings on Earth.
Thanks to an attempt to cure cancer that mutated
into a deadly virus, most humans have become
pallid, vampiric creatures.
Balancing mind-numbing loneliness with his
attempts to survive and develop a cure, Neville
soon finds that he is far less alone than
he initially suspected.
Grounded by a heartfelt performance by Will
Smith and featuring more action than the vast
majority of films on this list, I Am Legend
is a punchy, big-budget take on an apocalyptic ur-text.
"Please say 'Hello,' to me."
This film tells of a uniquely terrifying plague,
which only attacks strains of grasses and
grains, including wheat and rice.
In the wake of this catastrophe, the world
descends into famine, and, consequently, chaos.
We follow an upper-middle class architect
named John, who becomes the de facto patriarch
of a group of family, friends, and stragglers
as they make their way to the safe haven of
his brother's farm.
Pay no attention to the film's middling Rotten
Tomatoes score: What No Blade of Grass lacks
in polish and a finer touch it more than makes
up for in grim, stifling ecological terror.
Enduringly relevant and dystopian, No Blade
of Grass is an essential watch for anyone
with a taste for the dreary, hopeless outlook
of 1970s science fiction.
Ralph Burton is a miner who is trapped underground
while a nuclear holocaust wipes out all of humanity.
Emerging to find New York City deserted, Ralph
assumes he's the last man on Earth, and starts
acting like it.
Eventually, Ralph meets Sarah, a fellow survivor.
However, their dynamic is soon disturbed by
the arrival of another survivor.
Starring the trailblazing screen star and
activist Harry Belafonte, The World, the Flesh,
and the Devil feels like a lost Twilight Zone
episode filtered through the lens of Richard Matheson.
Tackling its societal themes head-on and highlighting
Belafonte's undeniable screen presence, this
film is an unmissable and decidedly more optimistic
entry in apocalyptic cinema.
Sunshine dramatizes a horrific, world-ending
scenario: The sun is dying.
As the planet Earth is thrust into colder
and colder temperatures, a team of crack astronauts
are sent to kick-start the all-important star
by firing a nuclear bomb into its core.
Full of incredible visuals and shocking horror
beats, particularly in the third act, Sunshine
is an enthralling and atmospheric slice of
science fiction with stakes that don't just
threaten humanity, but our whole solar system.
This sci-fi survival horror film and Cloverfield
sequel follows Michelle, a young woman who
wakes up in an underground bunker after a
violent roadside accident.
Unsettled by her domineering captor, Howard,
who claims the air outside is toxic and she
cannot leave under any circumstances, resourceful
Michelle sets about plotting her escape.
"Please, just let me go.
Please."
"There is nowhere to go, Michelle."
This economically paced and wildly tense single-location
thriller boasts numerous top-shelf performances
and a claustrophobic sense of unease.
If the world ended and you were trapped underground
with an overbearing psycho, what would you do?
From its title, you'd be forgiven for mistaking
this film for some kind of adorable sea-side romantic comedy.
It is, in fact, about an atomic war that wipes
out all organic life in the Northern Hemisphere.
A surviving yankee submarine finds respite
in Australia, which appears to be one of the
few safe harbors on Earth.
Where many films on this list veer into action
or hard sci-fi territory, On the Beach opts
for melodrama.
Sure, there's still plenty of nihilism and
social commentary, but on the whole, it feels
much more like an existential soap opera than
an explosion-heavy thriller.
On the Beach pulls this off by featuring a
powerful ensemble cast full of big-name talent.
Adapted from the 1962 French film La Jetée,
12 Monkeys follows James Cole, a convict from
the year 2035 sent through time to find a
solution to the world's dark fate.
In 1996, a deadly virus of unknown origin
eradicated almost all life on Earth, forcing
those who survived underground.
The plan is to send Cole back to the day of
the outbreak to learn how it all went down.
But when he's accidentally transported too
far back, his warnings of the end of days
land him in a mental hospital.
Boasting evocative production design and expectation-subverting
performances from its two male leads, 12 Monkeys
is a frantic, doom-filled ride with both style
and substance.
A Boy and His Dog takes place in the barren,
irradiated wastes of 2024.
Our hero is Vic, a morally suspect teenage
boy who wanders from one bombed-out hole in
the ground to the next in search of food and
women.
Along for the ride is Blood, a telepathic
dog full of wry commentary.
"Charity is a thing of the past."
This film is bleak, perverse, and offbeat
— aka, the holy trinity of 1970s apocalyptic
science fiction.
If you shook your fists at those who held
super-spreader house parties during the COVID-19
pandemic, boy have we got the film for you!
A top-shelf product of Roger Corman and Vincent
Price's yen for Edgar Allan Poe adaptations,
The Masque of the Red Death follows Prince
Prospero, a hedonistic Satanist who has resolved
to lock himself and his party guests in his
enormous castle to stave off the terrible
plague known as the Red Death.
Full of cruelty, scene-chewing, and gorgeous
production design realized in jaw-dropping
Technicolor, The Masque of the Red Death is
a lavish visual feast of gothic delights that
overcomes its budgetary limitations to deliver
one of the most striking products of Corman's career.
When animal rights activists unwittingly release
a rabies-like virus onto the British public,
the country is catapulted back to the Dark
Ages.
Four weeks later, a man named Jim wakes from
a coma and surveys the wreckage of what used
to be London.
Rescued by a group of survivors, Jim finds
that infected humans now stalk the streets,
transformed into frothing, homicidal maniacs.
Infusing the zombie genre with kinetic new
life, 28 Days Later proved the zombie genre
still had life in it yet.
In the aftermath of a top-secret experiment
designed to create a global energy source,
a scientist named Zac Hobson awakens to find
that he is the last person alive on Earth
— or so he thinks.
Soon, Hobson happens upon two other survivors.
As the trio discovers the common cause behind
their survival, their emerging love triangle
takes a backseat to Hobson's revelation that
the full extent of the experiment's pernicious
effects have yet to reveal themselves.
Overwhelmingly cryptic and appropriately lonely,
The Quiet Earth is a gorgeously photographed
low-budget gem grounded by three soul-wrenching
lead performances.
Boasting an incredible ensemble cast and an
unsettling degree of plausibility, Contagion
details the arrival and fallout of an airborne
viral pandemic.
This film's procedural plot makes the spread
that much more compelling and terrifying.
We follow the illness as it takes root, spawns
conspiracy theories, and destabilizes society.
Contagion makes particularly major use of
Soderbergh's talent for depicting catastrophes
and hyper-competence in equal measure.
This film was a nerve-wracking watch in 2011,
and has only become more uncanny and unsettling
in the wake of the eerily similar COVID-19
pandemic.
This iconic film may not initially read as
apocalyptic fiction, but brace yourself for
a 60-year-old spoiler.
When the plot's larger context is ultimately
revealed, its qualification as "end of days"
cinema becomes painfully, ironically obvious.
This film follows George Taylor, an astronaut
stranded on a strange planet dominated by
sentient ape-like creatures who use human
captives for sport and scientific experiments.
"Get your stinking paws off me, you damn,
dirty ape."
Still one of the bleakest films to come out
of Hollywood, Planet of the Apes features
a grounded performance from Roddy McDowall
as the benevolent chimp Dr. Cornelius, and
closes with one of the most infamous final
shots in all of cinema.
When Curtis begins to experience terrifying
hallucinations, he seeks medical help and counseling.
While Curtis' work and family suffer in the
wake of his violent outbursts and horrifying
visions of environmental catastrophe, he can't
shake the feeling that something truly terrible
is on the horizon.
Are these dreams a genuine premonition of
an incoming apocalypse ... or are they actually
the onset of the inherited schizophrenia he's
feared his whole life?
A genuinely gripping portrait of the erosive
effects of undiagnosed mental illness, Take
Shelter is a gripping, anxiety-riddled viewing
experience grounded by a gut-wrenching lead
performance from Michael Shannon.
Just as Harry is preparing to go on his first
date with his dream girl, he accidentally
receives a chilling tip-off that nuclear missiles
are going to destroy Los Angeles in less than
an hour.
While Harry initially laughs off the information
as a cruel joke or the ravings of a madman,
he soon learns that the threat is very real
and very imminent.
Balancing endearingly unrelenting romantic
idealism with an undeniable sense of hopelessness,
this Tangerine Dream-scored neon-lit terror
trip is a love story for the end times.
This genre-defying feature debut follows Byeong-gu,
an unemployed conspiracy nut who has convinced
himself that his former employer is an evil
alien who intends to take over the planet.
As such, Byeong-gu abducts his boss and tortures
him in a subterranean dungeon.
As his paranoia spreads and his "alien" torture
operation grows larger and larger, the resultant
chaos grows ever more intense.
Genre-defying and delightfully ridiculous,
there is no film quite like "Save the Green
Planet!" and for that fact alone, it's well
worth seeking out.
Directed by the Australian auteur Peter Weir,
The Last Wave follows David Burton, a taxation
lawyer who is hired to act as the defense
in a murder case involving the death of an
Aboriginal man during a freak rainstorm.
When Burton begins to experience bizarre,
watery dreams, he starts to agree with the
accused: The strange weather patterns are
a sign of an incoming apocalypse.
Ambiguous and lyrical, The Last Wave is steeped
in otherworldly strangeness as reality refuses
to sit still.
History may remember Saul Bass for his graphic
design, but fans of apocalyptic fiction know
his first and only directorial effort stands
toe-to-toe with the kinetic typography of Psycho.
A pair of scientific researchers in the Arizona
desert find themselves held captive by the
objects of their study: A colony of ants who
have begun acting strangely in the wake of
an unprecedented cosmic event.
As the global implications of their ant-imposed
lockdown take hold, driving the pair to nihilism
and madness, humankind reveals itself to be
an outmatched and overconfident species.
Misanthropic and enormous in its scale, "Phase
IV" takes the creature feature formula and
endows it with a desperate sense of fatalism.
When a pair of employees at a medical supply
warehouse accidentally unleash a deadly gas,
the malignant vapors begin to raise the dead.
What's more, the warehouse's neighbors are
a cemetery and a crematorium.
In short, this is a recipe for disaster.
As the dead wrench themselves back into the
land of the living, they only have one thing
on their minds:
"Brains."
One of the most confident directorial debuts
in horror history, The Return of the Living
Dead is a rare breed: A horror-comedy that
truly delivers on the horror, both in the
gore department and in confronting the existential
probability that mankind is going to pratfall
into its own destruction.
A séance unleashes a horrifying glimpse of
a long-dead priest and seemingly kills the
woman who experiences the vision.
While other occult-leaning women attempt to
warn the powers that be of the bad vibes,
the seer herself — who is very much alive
— is rescued from her grave by a passing journalist.
Together, the pair digs deeper into the vision,
uncovering an imminent prophecy of undead invasion.
Arguably one of the gnarliest offerings from
Italian goremaster Lucio Fulci, City of the
Living Dead boasts unparalleled style and
a refusal to dial down any of its apocalyptic spectacle.
The final product is a miraculous and foreboding
piece of filmmaking.
Based on Michael Crichton's 1969 novel, The
Andromeda Strain begins with a mysterious
catastrophe: The residents of a rural New
Mexico town all die after the crash landing
of a satellite.
The only survivors are an alcoholic man and
a screaming infant.
Suspecting the satellite may have brought
a vicious alien organism into Earth's atmosphere,
a group of scientists conduct an investigation
in a top-secret lab armed to self-destruct
if any infectious agent threatens to escape.
Featuring science fiction harder than a diamond
with a procedural bent that will satisfy those
with a love of 1970s conspiracy thrillers,
The Andromeda Strain is the cruel pinnacle
of the killer virus sub-genre.
Few end-of-days scenarios can contend with
the literally Earth-shattering catastrophe
that befell our planet roughly 66 million
years ago.
Directed by Don Bluth, the former Disney artist
who dominated children's feature animation
during the 1980s, The Land Before Time tells
of a group of young dinosaurs who are separated
from their families during unprecedented environmental
shifts.
As they journey through the wasteland, the
group is hounded by predators and a planet
keen to snuff out their young lives.
As dire, ominous, and distressing as any of
the "adult" films on this list, The Land Before
Time is a masterful story of perseverance,
devastation, and the difficult necessity of
accepting loss.
Even though it's supposed to be the happiest
day of her life, Justine is absolutely miserable
throughout her wedding.
She's doing her best, but her severe depression
shows through the cracks, much to the embarrassment
of her controlling sister, Claire.
Meanwhile, an immense blue planet, Melancholia,
is on a collision course with Earth.
As the gargantuan celestial object bears down
on our planet, Justine finds elation and peace
in the promise of imminent destruction.
Claire, on the other hand, descends further
and further into anxiety and panic as her
helplessness gets the better of her.
Weaponizing cataclysmic destruction as a metaphor
for all-consuming depressive episodes, Melancholia
is a masterful, engulfing, necessarily draining
watch.
The year is 2027 and humanity has become sterile.
As extinction looms, the planet's populace
descends into martial law and total fury.
We follow Theo, a former activist who is recruited
by his anti-authority ex-wife to shepherd
a very special woman to sanctuary.
No human baby has been born in nearly 20 years,
and yet somehow, this woman is pregnant.
With a startlingly believable vision of dystopia
grounded in impeccably detailed production
design and unforgettable cinematography, Children
of Men isn't just one of the best pieces of
apocalyptic fiction, but one of the greatest
sci-fi films of the 21st century.
Aliens have invaded Earth, and not as little
green men, but as microscopic, gelatinous
spores capable of imitating and assimilating
into the populace of prospective victims.
Our hero is Matthew Bennell, a lab scientist
who begins to grow wise to the extraterrestrial
conspiracy as the signs of subversive takeover
peek through the cracks.
The question is, will he be able to alert
the powers that be before it's too late?
Who can he confide in when the enemy looks
like a carbon copy of the people he trusts?
For our money, it's the fourth entry in the
Mad Max franchise that takes the cake… or,
more accurately, the can of beans, or the
barrel of guzzolene.
In all honesty, there's probably no cake to
be found in this apocalypse, but Mad Max:
Fury Road is a cut above its predecessors.
A feature-length car chase led by a rebellious
Imperator attempting to shepherd a warlord's
brides to a safe haven, this film is a kinetic
rock opera of dust clouds, skull-embedded
wheels, and dogged perseverance.
A modern classic with a wasteland we are keen
to revisit time and time again, Mad Max: Fury
Road is the shiny, chromatic star of modern
apocalyptic cinema.
"They're coming to get you, Barbara!"
For reasons unknown — though radiation from
a disintegrating space probe may be to blame
— the dead are rising from their graves.
A group of survivors fleeing the rotting hordes
find themselves under one roof, where they're
forced to steady their fragile nerves and
work together to keep the flesh-hungry ghouls
at bay.
A groundbreaking, precedent-setting contribution
to the apocalyptic genre, Night of the Living
Dead set the stage for a litany of zombie
films keenly interested in the human response
to the end of days.
Even more than 50 years past its initial release,
Night of the Living Dead refuses to show its age.
The stir-crazy residents of an Antarctic research
station find themselves in a Lovecraftian
nightmare when the dog they rescued explodes
into a fleshy mass of spider legs and bullwhip tentacles.
This high-stakes murder mystery is less of
a whodunit than a whoisit, which unfolds as
the men are preyed upon by an intergalactic
creature capable of imitating organic life.
The gem in the crown of John Carpenter's "Apocalypse
Trilogy" — which also contains the exceptional
"Prince of Darkness" and "In the Mouth of
Madness" — "The Thing" is a dread-drenched epic.
This is the way the world ends: Not with a
bang, but with miscommunication and politicians
fighting in the war room.
However, there is also a bang for good measure.
Simultaneously one of the scariest and funniest
films ever made, Stanley Kubrick's satirical
masterpiece focuses on a gaggle of politicians,
generals, and diplomats attempting to thwart
an unintended nuclear holocaust instigated
by an American general maddened by conspiracy theories.
Horrifyingly plausible and undeniably hilarious,
Dr. Strangelove is a classic for a reason.
A guide, known as a "stalker" in the film,
shepherds two curious men through a bizarre
area known as "the Zone."
Mysterious and forbidden, the Zone is a physics-defying
land at the epicenter of an unspeakable extraterrestrial tragedy.
In the core of the Zone lies their destination:
The Room, a mystical space that seems to grant
the deepest, darkest wishes of all who enter
it.
Directed by the great Soviet filmmaker Andrei
Tarkovsky, "Stalker" is an evasive, yet evocative,
take on science fiction's deepest questions.